quand même il ya eu un problème c'est
pas la première fois me semble-t-il
confessions de freeze dans pékin express
est que plus on en avait déjà eu un
c'était en 2008 c'est le canard enchaîné
qui avait sorti gagnant d'un ancien
membre de la production qui disait qu'il
y avait une ligne éditoriale pour
favoriser certains candidats et pourquoi
pas les 5 années
alors justement saisine c'est tombé dans
la nuit ça a fait grand bruit
ça m'a empêché de dormir la nuit c'est
tombé à 28 1 twitpic et camille qui
t'ont fait et qui mettait en avant une
image en fait visiblement il y aurait il
y aurait une voiture qui attendait le
duo des deux free des deux femmes qui
arrivent et clients qui ont qui on gagne
1 elle est là on voit bien le plan la
carte est candidate
alors évidemment nous quand on a vu ça
notre sang n'a fait qu'un tour
je vous déplacer on a enquêté et toute
la nuit a wish ans il part dans
l'oreillette
l'avocat n'a pas dormi de la nuit on
était visionné toutes les toutes les
séquences dont vous étiez ensemble toute
la nuit à visionner cette séquence donc
ils ont balancé ce tweet on a enquêté
regardez les images comme dirait l'autre
c'est édifiant ou la la banalité de
laetitia et aurélie prend fin les deux
soeurs sont à nouveau dans la course
une voiture à droite il faut absolument
trouver une voiture tout de suite la
première voiture pour rejoindre stéphane
pont qui reliera parquet d osaka
pas d'émotion manosque alpha bah voilà
oui ok c'est dans la piscine
il accepte tout de suite de nous amener
devant stéphane et là on a juste envie
de faire ce qu'ils aiment bien parce que
là l'heure est grave
moi je ne peux pas tolérer des choses
pareilles oui même si c'est moi mais
vous le prenez pour des cons les
productions vous croyez qu'il médite
riches comme ça et qu'ils vont laisser
la voiture comme ça juste derrière alors
je vous dis c'est que les émissions de
télé et je peux vous dire que parfois
quand on triche on se prends pas ma
question c'est est ce qu'on la revoit
une deuxième fois la boîte alors
justement on se fait dicter leur loi qui
s'est dit prêt d'ici cette voie si la
voiture était si facile à trouver
peut-être que c'est le cas dans notre
situation visiblement ce binôme à chaque
fois qu'ils veulent trouver une voiture
à la voiture elle dit oui et l'autre
binôme motivant une bagnole ils disent
non donc c'est quand même mais curieux à
ce que ce soit si il ya même un extrait
où le mec il dit même pas oui il dit est
dit comme ça c'est fait que ses deux
filles a permis au max la regarder c'est
pour reprendre la course à l'essai
laetitia aurélie sont soulagés elles ont
enfin accompli leur mission mais perdu
un temps considérable
elles doivent au plus vite trouver une
voiture sous la coupe
agnès gracieuse il faut absolument
rattraper notre retard face à moon irait
à lydia le temps c'est de l'argent
on ne perd pas une seconde donc là bon
là ils ont la preuve d orgueil galère
ailleurs gène rhône colline mazda x3
deuxième étape là vous allez voir c'est
encore plus flagrant en iran va voler
comme jamais aujourd'hui je veux
récupérer mon argent le moindre centime
bien faut vite qu'on trouvait de
voitures voilà on y parlait de
l'enseigné à une compétition française
nécessite au mal que j'ai mes armes à la
main par à la guerre j'y vais comme si
j'avais les paladins escura pour essayer
d'avoir la première voiture n'est pas
locale
elmer pierre osho notre cadeau bédié va
nous chanter une comptine pas la sias
pas en train de partir [ __ ]
ils sont attendus à temps fini on est on
a mené enquête toute la nuit
[Rires]
moon et mounir et lydia qui galèrent les
filles un peu moins mais c'est pas fini
alors là il ya même une séquence s'est
même pas la voiture qu'ils arrêtent la
voiture à la temps non et oui vous ne
pourrez pas un peu pour des cons
regardez leur bus venait voir y'a qu'une
bagnole en plus un rôle laetitia et
aurélie obtiennent immédiatement
l'adresse de l'arrivée sans plus
attendre les deux soeurs se met à
rechercher un nouveau véhicule d'essai
concours jeu
incroyable laetitia et aurélie partent
en première position du monument des
héros venir et lydia qui peinait à
arrêter les véhicules finniste enfin
convaincre un chauffeur dans la foulée
des deux seuls
là excusez moi le mais il ya une bagnole
carnac unis il n'y en a pas deux au
milieu de la route
mais ces gars il ya un an qu'il comme ça
bon et surtout il dit même pas oui c'est
vrai on regarde il est comme ça et dire
oui il faut montrer aux toilettes quand
même mais non c'est très étrange a dit
l'essentiel
je suis tenu ces noms sur des noms
s'agit là c'est très étrange c'est un
nouveau toute l'année ont été pêchés
tous les reçus il a regardé tous ses
combats ses cordes
c'est tout l'édifice qui vacille c'est
une déflagration et en fait quand vous
regardez l'épisode tous les conducteurs
qui les prennent
non jamais l'air surpris oui et ce jeu
il regarde la caméra ils n'ont pas l'air
surpris d'être filmé et je dirais même
plus que dans les voitures
il ya des passages et accompagnants
quand l'air totalement à l'aise
complètement habitués à voir des gens à
côté d'eux on a vraiment l'impression
que les voitures attendent et que le
conducteur ait au moins des passagers
sont complices et mardi pardon et on
peut se parler franchement je peux vous
dire vraiment sauver l'amour dans les
foyers bien qu'un montage quand même
alors moi je suis pas d'accord pour dire
qu'il ya de la triche je pense que ses
deux filles donc évidemment on avez vous
remarqué le monde qu'avec des hommes les
hommes s'arrêtent quand il voit deux
nanas qui font du stop
essayez vous verrez si vous faites du
stop the gallery
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et là elle a fait ils vont s'arrêter
pierre savelli courez vite quand même
c'est une question c'est pas vrai il ya
des passagères dans les voitures à
chaque fois c'est pas des sorties ce qui
les attendent
mais on attendait juste juste un truc le
montage
je suis d'accord avec vous mais
l'intérêt c'est de faire un suspense est
pas montré des mourides qu'elles ont
galéré pas de montrer cadre une bagnole
tout de suite effectivement donc je vous
retourne la question quel serait
l'intérêt de faire gagner ses deux
filles plutôt que d'autres concurrents
catus alors on déjà déjà le couple
allait et moins sympathique parce qu'il
se passe dans son anglais tout le temps
et qu'il fallait trouver ça fait et
deuxièmement pour l'émission c'est quand
même pas mal vu le contexte sociétal
actuel qu'un couple de jeunes femmes ont
remporté des missions moi je trouve ça
plus en affichage ça s'est passé deux
heures de sa comment et puis à pleines
dents mais il ya plein de tweets
conditions puisque c'est le même normal
cette histoire de triche dans chaque
émission gilles en parle régulièrement
cette histoire de triche dans la
production ce n'est pas normal
et là pour moi c'est un angle mort du
csa qui n'est pas du tout abord je pense
que les chaînes ont une convention avec
le csa où ils ont eus ont un devoir
d'honnêteté et truites riche et truquées
tromper le téléspectateur ce n'est pas
normal et je trouvais j'avais interrogé
d'ailleurs justement quelques des
services du csa qui dit que oui là
justement on ne sait pas quoi faire et
on n'a aucune information sur ce sujet
là et je pense que le csa devra enquêter
pour voir si on peut pas tricher
vis-à-vis des téléspectateurs comme ça à
venir a juste tout comme ça la
providence et être honnête
enfin une vraie confidence je fais des
jeux d'aventuré même si on veut pas
volontairement une production tricher
quand vous êtes dans une recherche de
trésors que vous avez des caméras mais
qu'ils ont postés à différents endroits
à huy et qu'il ya une recherche d'un
objet particulier vous doutez bien que
les candidats et qui plus est
aujourd'hui kikou ils connaissent tous
les codes de la télé quand ils voient ce
jeu est bien d'accord utile et c'est pas
très nouveau c'est le cas dans c'est le
cas dans koh lanta c'était le cas dans
l'émission que remarquable que j'ai fait
pour pour ces huit vaches highland
cacher
mais on volait pas les aider mais
forcément les cadreurs sont positionnés
à dessert la télévision malheureusement
sa desserte et ses portes du renne
défiance des téléspectateurs vis-à-vis
d'un programme
c'est dommage mais comme heures pour
vous christine poney au point car il ya
tricherie ou non oui rires ouais bah oui
oui mais non ils étaient toutes les
nages non non respect pour encore une
fois c'est pareil pour les jeux sunu
tout le monde sait qu'aujourd'hui dans
les cartouches et des jeux il ya
différentes que des vraies questions
moyennement difficile très difficile ou
facile c'est autorisé ça serait pas
possible amérique si bas en amérique
vous êtes obligés de déposer le plan de
vol de votre émission cercle dont vous
avez la question de miro une jusqu'à la
dernière en france sur les millions on
sait très bien que les questions peuvent
être changées aux furieux que ça avance
c'est pas un secret le csa devrait le
savoir puisque les bras en tout cas
c'est la télévision elle même qui va en
matière parce que cette défiance qu'on a
à vous avez déjà de tout des pouvoirs
publics et cetera des politiques et ben
on l'a de plus en plus avec ce genre de
programme et c'est dommage
est-ce qu'on devrait respecter ces deux
américaines sont possibles la part du
csa
si c'était avéré une petite sion est
clairement est clairement favorisé un
duo et qu'est ce qu'ils risquent ce qui
risque il risque une mise en garde une
nuit une mise en demeure ensuite il
faudra rouler au prix trois bris par
exemple maintenant mais il faut que le
csa est la preuve pour l'asse c'est la
preuve que ça parce que c'est ça viala
dans la convention entre une chaîne est
là il suffit de regarder l'émission
aujourd'hui par des nantais la preuve
les la bassée
est ce qu'aujourd'hui christine kelly
vous que ces cahiers vous demander
officiellement oui au csad enquêter sur
la fenêtre de de pékin express abattent
vous savez quoi j'avais eu le dire
justement quand je demande
officiellement au c'est ça non seulement
d'enquêtés sur pékin tous les jeux mais
surtout les jeux pourquoi parce que
c'est la télé qui va en pâtir
aujourd'hui on est dans un sauvetage de
la télévision française je suis désolé
on est dans le trou à l'étagé la
télévision le toilettage des lois la
réforme de l'audiovisuel qui va passer
bientôt est passé à la fin du mois de
septembre c'est ça justement je trouve
que dans cette réforme audiovisuelle non
beaucoup de choses on doit justement
l'idée est de plus en plus honnête et
transparent avec le téléspectateur et il
y va de l'avenir de la télé l'appel est
lancé merci beaucoup